[Music]
well I feel like that you're never
really too far but you you take like a
mini break and you're never really too
far you're working on stuff but yeah
you're back yeah whole album and we're
happy back in the world and it's good
beautiful trauma I love it and I need to
know where it came from the the name of
that ring I always name the album after
a song I don't know why I just always
have but I feel like life is really
traumatic really dramatic
every time you look around there's
something happening but I also think
that there's a lot of beautiful people
in the world there's a lot of good
people and there's a lot of love to be
made and fun to be had and I think human
beings are really resilient and I look
at my husband who is this beautiful man
who's covered in scars and every scar is
just it's an incredible story of intense
trauma that he's survived and the key
word is survived and I think that his
scars are the most beautiful thing about
him that's interesting because when I
read it I started laughing because I
always call myself a beautiful mess and
and I when I was reading the New York
Times article that they they said I had
mostly cooked chicken but what you said
was and I say there's so much and I have
people that argue with me all the time
but I believe it to my core you said you
know you look in the mirror sometimes
and you say you can't have it all
there's always a compromise why do you
believe that because I'm I'm I'm really
into the psychology of things and and I
look at the way we have evolved and
progressed as women and the things that
we've had to fight for and and why are
we fighting for those things and what is
it that we really want what is it that I
want what does it mean to
each individual woman to have it all
what does that actually mean and to be a
working woman with a family with a
relationship I have to tell you a lot of
ways I would say what is she talking
about at all and I'm blessed beyond
belief
I have enough but if I every time I make
one decision I take away from something
else what is it that you think you don't
have or that you're missing well I would
love to get rid of some of the mom guilt
oh because that really shades a lot of
my decision-making there's a lot of
stuff that I watch
I just think men are better at walking
out the door and shutting it off and
going and doing what they do whereas
when I walk out the door I leave my
heart behind and it's it's conflicting
it's always conflicting and I want to be
the best mom in the world I put way too
much pressure on myself I think we all
do yeah and I want to follow my passion
too and I want my kids to see what it
looks like to have a mom that's a boss
that that is following her passion and
that is working really hard towards her
goals and but there's always a choice
it's a choice for each thing you do
there's a choice it's a balance it's
interesting that you say that though
because and I'm a little surprised at
that because to see when you were
getting the video Vanguard Award and to
see how your little girl was looking at
you and to see like how she was
mimicking what you you said and singing
your songs and taking so much joy and
her mom up there yeah like that kind of
it floors me because I'm like how does
she have this mom cuz look at this
little girl hair obviously you are her
heroine because no matter what you just
it's not good enough I don't know we put
that on ourselves that's how we mom now
is just never good enough but having her
with me and having the kind of life that
I have that's why I say I'm blessed
beyond belief because I can bring my kid
with me my kids go with me on tour and
they have this incredible diverse
beautiful carnival
people between my dancers and my band
and wardrobe and and our chef Robbie who
teeth taught her how to cook when she
was two and it's just this this gypsy
family of traveling people and that
part's beautiful that part's beautiful
how do you not sit invite that little
ones face I do and his but he has little
man shrivel but right now and I'm so
into it and I can't stop squeezing it
[Laughter]
wouldn't you post the pictures of them
like those cheeks like boy I know um
when you're crafting this album where
did you draw from because I know you
always say you draw from your life
experience yeah so what place are you in
now and because I have a vision of from
listening to the album like okay maybe
this was going on this was in their head
song on it's all in my head there's
about 17 voices in my head and I draw
from all of them I like this is the
longest I've had to they say your first
album takes 20 years and your second
album takes six months and so I've been
on that six months sort of thing for a
really long time and this time I was
living my life and and I'm going on
marches and watching the news and
watching this world become a different
world and and raising my kids and doing
bake sales and trying to be a wife and
trying to have a long-term relationship
and and also making records and songs
and and it's all there it's just I'm
just a human being trying to put one
foot in front of the other just like
everybody else
I thought what about us was maybe about
you and Carrie but it's not it's about
for me it's about how government has
failed us and not just in this country
especially in this country but in
general I just think there's so many
people that are being made to feel
lesser than and it's not right and it's
it shouldn't be it's 2017 and this is
not the world that I want to teach my
daughter about
and again I I always try to go back to
there's a lot of good people in this
world that want good things and somehow
we have to I mean human beings are
resilient when I went to Haiti it is the
poorest country in the world and people
are dancing in the street and I hold
that in my heart that we will overcome
all of it mm-hmm and yeah so all of that
is swirling around in my head constantly
you're more M&M making news today that
that he's one of the best freestylers
anyway period that came from like the
depths of death
oh yes he did the collaboration with you
all was was it fun was it crazy was it
so fun yeah he makes me laugh I love him
I think he's a genius and I was drinking
a lot of wines when I wrote that song
and when you get home you just drink
more wine and then I emailed them
professed my undying love for him and
said please be on this record and he
said yes that quick that easy yeah yeah
so okay were you guys together or did
you do it SEP no I think he was in Rio
de Janeiro oh my gosh so yeah I got it
four days later and I cracked up and
it's my mom's favorite song it's a good
one it's a good one to have funds on I
know what part cuz she's laughing I was
thinking the chorus when I was on the
plane last night and like I know people
probably like yeah oh you said that you
take your kids on tour with yes how do
you do that I mean Tori and itself is
crazy but how do you do that I do yoga
sometimes do a lot of downward dogs is
that your workout regimen when you're on
the road because you're so lot of cardio
yeah
a lot of acrobatic rehearsals and yoga
we all do yoga together as a team it's
nice it's really nice go at it to keep
everybody together just
your family ever say can you just keep
your feet on the ground once there's a
mom as well many times about me and my
husband it's not gonna happen how do you
top yourself every time when you know
that people are expecting cause that's
that because you have to you have to up
the ante here you have to the older I
get the the more dangerous it becomes
do you have any must-haves when you're
on the road like things that you have to
have with you or there just has to be a
lot of soft carpeting in the room
because there's Babies everywhere and it
yeah I'm tired of baby proofing yeah
okay so I know I have a favorite pink
song do you have a favorite pink song it
depends on the day I guess really
depends on it what's your favorite song
great Harry Hart my favorite one today
off the new record or just in general
yes in general do you have a favorite
that you've done um I think maybe Ojai
have no idea a family portrait dear mr.
president I don't know mm-hmm perfect to
me that's like an anthem which one the
perfect perfect yeah it's an anthem for
me the thing I love about performing
that now now that I have a six year old
girl is watching moms and daughters in
the audience just hug each other and
watching moms pick out lines from the
song and point at their daughters face
and just trying to drill it into their
head and grown men crying it's just it's
it's a nice moment it's very fun that
you put on when in your house when
you're at home and you just dance it is
it really really is that song for me um
I know you you were horrified by Las
Vegas I mean yeah you performed there we
we were all horrified when you found
that out did you where did your heart go
did go to fear did it go to I'm about to
go on tour did it go - ain't no way
somebody's stopping this show or gonna
make us all of the above yeah honestly I
was numbed for a couple of days and that
was what scared me because I think
desensitise
is one of the worst things and then I
read the LA Times article where they
went they talked about all of the
victims and their families and their
kids and I just I've cried a lot it's
hard not to it's just it's it's
devastating I feel bad for everybody I
still feel bad for Ariana Grande she's
so young and to live with that
responsibility for the rest of your life
is just it's heartbreaking yeah I mean
what can you say it's it's absolutely
heartbreaking I hate a lot and I don't
use the word hate in my house because
I'm trying to teach my daughter to use
better words but I hate a lot of what's
happening in our world it's it's just
it's it's mind-numbing I said to someone
the other day my soul is stretched yeah
my soul is really fatigued yeah and
because and you just think what what
next and why I think that's why I keep
having to go back to that there's beauty
in the world that there's still love and
people are still good and and I just I
ultimately have to believe that that
it's gonna be okay yeah and and you do
your part to make it so that's all you
can do okay
um is there a nightlife yes switching
gears no cuz I'm like I'm about my
eyelashes on brother
hey thanks makeup artist all right are
you just gonna sing I'm just gonna sing
I'm just try not to talk I'm just gonna
sing uh yeah I think I'm just gonna sing
mm-hmm no skits I don't know yet I hope
so
as I was saying I would like you I would
like to I did one back in the day I
haven't been on SNL in 12 years I think
I've been kicked out every time I've
been there what are you playing we don't
remember the second time I was in my 20s
huh you're supposed to get kicked out of
places
right you got kicked out of SNL you
gotta keep that like the after part I
think the after party it's from what
I've been told the last time I talked to
you was at the VMAs and I think I told
you and
Carrie y'all earned each other oh I know
my good and bad I'm like you two have
earned each other I know when you say
things like that to him I know exactly
where his head goes and I want to smack
him in public but he's a good man he is
he's super cute
you said it in an article you don't hand
your your wedding ring back I haven't so
much really long time I feel like we've
come a long way this is why I used to
throw it I think I threw it in the pool
once I was doing I was standing on top
of a grotto saying to all of his friends
oh yeah yeah lots of drama but then you
guys have made this incredible family
yeah dad and you I was gonna saying you
probably look back and you're like how
we did this yeah yeah yeah I believe in
the work I believe in it after you gave
that that speech at the VMAs did you
talk to your daughter did you did she
say anything cuz I mean you had us all
done
she wasn't super impressed that night
she was more concerned with her
sleepover and when that was gonna start
she did not want to go to dinner with us
but the first time we had the
conversation which was a couple of weeks
before I think it I think it meant a lot
to her and I think I think it was David
Bowie that kind of made it all make
sense to her because we loved the movie
labyrinth and he's the Goblin King in
labyrinth and she was like well is that
a boy or a girl and I was like right
epic she's like yeah yeah that's what
being a rock star is and I think also
her hearing that I get made fun of cuz
she's six and she thinks I'm awesome
she had doesn't yet despise me so she's
like what do you mean you get made fun
of you're perfect
what happens when that day comes when
she's like oh it's my it's like right
around the corner yeah issued good big
sister she is finally she likes him now
that he can laugh she likes him she was
very disappointed in him when he first
came out really yeah she thought he was
very boring and annoying so how did you
get her to like or did you just let her
it on her own time and have her own way
yeah I just kind of let her do it we had
a lot of talks a lot of Tears at one
point she looked at me and said I never
thought I'd have to beg you for a cuddle
with crocodile tears in her eyes and I
was like oh did that kill you yeah yeah
took about six months oh my I threw her
a big sister party I really thought I
dotted my eyes and cross my T's but it's
fine it'll be fine
one day she'll thank me I keep telling
her that she will do you do you have um
going back to the album I asked you if
you had a favorite song period but do
you have a favorite song on the album
revenge makes me happy
yeah cuz it's fun and I can be pretty
serious sometimes I think what about us
it's probably my favorite song I just
giorgia killed the video everybody in
that video was beautiful everywhere
there was tears all around I feel like
we nailed it and I loved to sing it it
feels good in my body and it's and it's
the right thing it was on in the gym
this morning the video was I was on the
elliptical else that you said recently
of course perks the interest when you
said you you had never been as big as
Britney or Christina I don't know if I
agree with that really yeah I mean maybe
just in my purview but I don't know if I
could you've so what 40 something
million out of 42 million albums
actually I wrote it down you um like
you've released a single every year
since 2000 except for one year you've
had like yeah I read that too I was like
really for real number one hits you know
11 more top-ten hits what do you mean
you're not as big as them I don't know I
just feel like that's the way it's
always been but I feel like it's a
blessing in disguise really I mean
because I would go I would go to Europe
and play arenas and have this big fancy
tour and then I would come back and play
like the 930 Club in DC to 200 people
and it's it's this rollercoaster and I
remember joking with Justin Timberlake
my first tour ever in 99 was opening for
N Sync and then
ten years later I'm open or not 10 years
but 2004 I was opening for Justin and it
screwed in the first day I saw him I was
like I've come far but that's a concert
though you ingest it was fun
that's a con but when I was when I was
on stage everyone was still in catering
like everyone was dressed as seats New
York Times also calls you a progressive
truth teller okay I thought that I'll
take it yeah yeah I like that time I'm
like you know it's kind of true like
that like you you kind of sneaked in on
us and you're like you're sneaky
dropping gyms it's not I'm dropping a
bomb seriously it's true I'm not very
subtle but I'll take it
do you think well because maybe maybe
it's just in your music I mean you - you
tell it like it t-i-is as my
grandmother's ladies but I mean
sometimes we may I just don't expect it
when it comes I'm like okay pink drop a
gym yeah I like to call it yeah I was
raised that way my dad's nickname was
mister cause so I'm a fighter there's a
lot to fight about right now there is
there is and there's a lot to talk about
talk about like when people better word
yeah I like when people use their
platform and use I don't like when
celebrities shy behind or you know that
everybody buy shoes or everybody buys
record so I'm not gonna say anything I
like when people take a stand in - I do
- I'm very polarizing I get that but I
don't mince words and I don't falter and
you know what I people do ask me
sometimes do you think celebrities have
a responsibility to have a cause and I
said if it's in them if it's not in you
then no you know you have a job just
like everybody else but if it's in you
then yeah you have a responsibility does
um just mom does mom call you Alicia
yeah so what's next in for Alicia and
not pink I have what is what's next I'm
trying to get this baby to grow some
teeth so I can start feeding them
different kinds of food I'm super
anxious about that I'm
ready to start with the finger foods
that's arrived at I'm hoping Kerry asked
me on a date soon because it's been a
while and it is date night for you guys
date night is if we're in Venice we ride
bicycles to our favorite dive bar play
darts or pool you guys just like it like
you'd like each other he's funny
yeah yeah he's he's naughty I like his
brain actually this last question um
because I've been to on TV talking all
morning of course about Harvey Weinstein
mm-hmm and so I just I've been asking
men and women this because the Terry
Crews stuff blew me away - that he said
he's experienced you know sexual
harassment and unwanted gestures by
people and she have you ever experienced
you know what's funny is no not really
I think people think I'll bite them I'm
not even kidding and I you know I've
always some some of my friends have been
through some gnarly stuff and I'm like
why can't I get in a room alone with a
guy like that but it just like I have so
much misplaced anger I need somewhere to
put it
I like no I mean no and and thank God
but I'm glad that it's not being
tolerated do you feel like a tide is
changing that women I do I think women
are supporting each other I think we
really have each other's backs and and
in that way if this is what's being
forced out of it then that's a silver
lining
[Music]